you know a lot of people learn from
books from Reading from seeing you know
um uh videos stuff like that I found
that I learn the best from chatting with
people conversations even arguing with
people and hearing you know kind of
Dynamics um so this is this is like a
good fit for me and this is like one of
my big biggest passion that I have um
and it relates to to the rest of of the
answer um at the end of the day as you
mentioned we need a learn a lot of um
domain specific Dynamics very very fast
and by the way that's a challenge um
that we all know in the investment world
right by definition when we meet a
Founders a team or a Founder um by
definition these Founders should know
that space better than us right if we
know that space better than them so
something like that's their that's what
they're going to put their next 10 years
of their lives into
[Music]
or barai welcome to a the Maas
experiment in 20 minute leaders I'm so
excited to hypothesize with you and to
understand your world and and and who
you are so thank you so much for being
here thank you for having me pleasure
awesome okay so aie we know each other
for quite some time we um are um in a
similar ecosystem we get to interact act
with very amazing people similar people
on the day today so I've I've grown to
have tremendous love and respect for you
over the years and today I have the
privilege of now diving a little bit
deeper and and really understanding your
your why and so today I really want to
focus the conversation on understanding
you a little bit better you know what
drives you and motivates you some of the
work that you're doing today at at team8
and as an investor and very active in
the Cyber EOS system um but really
understand you know what why is that so
exciting for you and what you know
especially in the point in time that we
live in today I think you're probably in
in my perspective one of the most
exciting spaces in the world and one of
the most exciting places in the world to
be in um and so aie again welcome
welcome to to this conversation tell me
a little bit about yourself and how you
even got into the space you're in
totally um so actually it's an
interesting story uh before being an
investor I started with product roles um
and even if we go um even more you know
uh to to a previous chapter I started in
the IDF like a lot of us I was in s
matkal in the special forces of the uh
um the intelligence Department um and I
was there in the in the technology
department within S mkal I was there a
team leader and then a product manager
um and then afterwards I became a
product manager with uh I led products
in startups so I uh I was a product
manager in an iot industry 4 company and
then a product manager in a cyber
security company in aass security
company um and I remember the moment
that uh Pango basically approached me um
asking whether I'm interesting to to
join the investment team um and this
relates to a question because uh I
remember me thinking it came a little
bit early to be honest um that approach
and that like um kind of option to get
into the investment world you know
there's a lot a lot of investors very
you know accomplished Founders um that
build companies sold companies maybe
ipoed companies and then in the second
chapter of their career they're going to
be a VC investor and I was like I had
like both feelings on one hand it was it
felt a little too early on the other
hand I had this strong feeling of um I
feel like it it's something I I should
do and it's something that it's it's
even even a bigger fit for for my you
know characteristic what um I find
interesting and um the deeper Insight
was that I always felt I'm more like a
broad person than a deep dive person um
so I really enjoyed the broader view of
seeing a lot of companies a lot of
Founders a lot of markets different
markets and not being focused only on
one specific vertical and I think this
is something that uh I feel today is a
very strong fit and it's something that
very like very much motivates me um in
my day-to-day and it's a very good fit
for being an investor you get to see a
lot and speak with so many and so much
um um educated smart um Innovative
people every single day um that that's
just fascinating so so this is what
drives me every day actually and and if
you if you look at your very practical
experience in in the IDF and in product
in in other areas as well H how does
that impact the relationship that you
have with the the different Founders you
you work with the opportunities that you
see the solutions that you're evaluating
how has how do you see your your
background being very handson in really
diving into the the value proposition
that you're creating and you're
generating um how is that impacting the
the way that the way and the shape of
your efforts today it's an interesting
question um I think there are two ways
um or maybe two parameters two
components um to think uh through so the
first one is the professional one I
think there's an interesting overlap
between being a product guy and an early
stade investment investor here in the
ecosystem the overlap is the is that as
being a product manager um you wake up
in the morning and the thing you you're
responsible of is thinking always about
the product Market fit and when you talk
about product Market fit you need a you
need you know kind of consider all kinds
of considerations so it needs to be the
right Market the right buyer Persona um
the right goto Market approach the right
technology um and you kind kind of need
um responsible to orchestrate all these
considerations and when you think about
it this is quite the way that we think
of things where as early stage investors
right we don't have data like growth
investors we don't have previous you
know outcome previous traction we're
trying to kind of predict a potential
product Market fit of a specific
technology in a specific Market with a
specific goto Market approach so this
kind of way of thinking and way of
analyzing things is a very good overlap
that I feel I leverage today so this is
on the professional side on the kind of
the network and the soft skill side um I
feel like you know at the end of the day
it's it's it's that isra ecosystem so
we're all leveraging the network that we
have the relationships that we have so
it's both on the IDF and our background
that we have um and and this kind of
intersects with soft kills that you you
should and and most of the product
managers have as being kind of
orchestrators so this is this is a good
fit as well to to and and and this is
something that you can leverage as well
being an early Ser investor so that's
like the second component I I love it
and I think that and I love the the the
the parallel that you're drawing for
early stage Investments and and product
management and and there and how you're
operating with a certain
unpredictableness but and and you're and
you're venturing out to to identify the
product Market fit which really is the
the art of of of what you did back then
and if we're diving in one one level
deeper you did choose to go from you
know working on very specific problem
spaces you know you mentioned you know
that the art of product Market fit is is
ultra Focus right you you're basically
constantly you know stripping away
layers of of of ambiguity and
generalizations to reach that that
really critical Persona with a really
critical paino now you get to do that
across many domains you have to very
quickly study new domains what what
skills did you need to now level up in
and how do you now find your daytoday
doing it on many different domains
versus on just one yeah um so so by the
way it relates to to your first question
um one of the reasons I I entered to the
invest investment world is you know a
lot of people learn from books from
Reading from seeing you know um uh
videos stuff like that I found that I
learn the best from chatting with people
conversations even arguing with people
and hearing you know know kind of
Dynamics um so this is this is like a
good fit for me and this is like one of
my big biggest passion that I have um
and it relates to to the rest of of the
answer um at the end of the day as you
mentioned we need to learn a lot of um
domain specific Dynamics very very fast
and by the way that's a challenge um
that we all know in the investment world
right by definition when we meet a
Founders a team or a Founder um by
definition these Founders should know
that space better than us right if we
know that space better than them so
something like that's their that's what
they're going to put their next 10 years
of their lives into um and that creates
the challenge of being a good investor
that you need to kind of ramp up really
fast to a certain level a certain
threshold in which you can really
analyze it and really achieve a
conviction and say okay this this is we
see the world um as they see we share
the same premise um and we want to bet
on this team in this market um and the
way to do it to do it um is gaining and
leveraging the the network that you have
so leveraging the network the buyers the
personas that you know within that
specific domain and getting their
insights and kind of confronting your
thoughts with them the second thing is
actually have a kind of a you know a a
background in that domain so you can
really you know you're not starting from
from zero right um and this is what we
do at teammate actually uh my teammate
we have kind of our a knowledge and
expertise that we already have in let's
say say a cyber security data AI
whatever we're we're dealing with and
then we're not starting from zero so at
the end of the day our ability to learn
fast a specific domain and that vertical
is very very good you know I've I I've
gotten to know quite a few VCS in the
space H mainly because I was also I also
had the privilege of being on the VC
space before before founding my company
and and I think it's pretty safe to say
that team8 is one of the most um one of
the most learning organizations I've
ever seen and what I mean by that is
that you really do act on the pr on the
promise of constantly learning from Real
World environment I got a chance to to
to take a small part in the recent ceso
Summit right and I was witnessing what
is it like to have a hundred pop cisos
sitting in a space where they in they
immerse themselves in curiosity sharing
in insights being extremely open and
present to these intellectual
conversations and witnessing both you
know the investing the investment team
of teammate in the room as well as some
found some founders of the teammate
portfolio just you know taking it all in
right and I can only and as investors
that ramp up that you're doing it's one
thing to do it in an existing category
in an existing domain that you want to
evolve in you're not always operating in
an existing domain a lot of times you're
acting in an arms race and there's new
threat attack vectors that are coming
out and you have to be able to identify
quickly what they mean and so I I I very
much realize and uh and am am hugely
impressed with how yourself and Lan and
adav and Israel and and all the great
team there you've built this this
learning mechanism do you do you
experience that in the day today totally
uh totally and um I have to to say look
by by the way I'm I'm you know I'm I'm
pretty new relatively new at teamate
right one and a half years now and the
credit is all you know the culture
building that that these guys have done
so the thing that I find most
interesting is it's kind of a culture um
uh culture thing of being humble and
assuming um that no matter how much you
know and how much you learn always
keeping your mind about what you don't
know and always keeping your mindset of
knowing more and this is like kind of an
humble approach that keeps us the C of
Village is a good example for that right
like assuming that the market always
changes always um evolves as you
mentioned attack attacks is is is a is
an example for that and for that purpose
we need to be with a pulse on the market
always to always be there with the
market engaging with the market you know
not not assuming that we already have
hold the premise or hold you know the
the Dynamics because they're they're
they're evolving continuously and this
is something that I I feel that um this
is something very unique at teammate
always being part of the market and
always being educated by the market and
not only you know assuming that we hold
the truth um and and and it translates
to it's not only a cliche or a title
it's it it translated as you mentioned
to operational real projects real
operational approach of teammate um and
it's part of our day-to-day yeah I I
think that uh this the the context in
which you you do it also so so well
connected to the environment that you
live in in the cyber security space it's
it's not just being intentional about
saying let's create a learning
environment let's bring some people who
are knowledgeable to be advisers and
represent you really do engage them with
with real conversations and real
outcomes and and and ultimately just
shows in the Investments you make and
and and the and the portfolio Founders
that that you back some of them are are
amazing friends of mine some of them are
investors in our compan so it's you
really see the culture that you're
creating transcend all the way down to
to the founders AI what what are you
most curious by today what what are you
most excited about yeah um I think there
are several things um obviously how AI
is changing um the world as we know it
is is a very interesting topic and I
think specifically um the interesting
thing is is what's our role here in
Israel in that uh kind of you know
Revolution right uh so a lot of people
kind of compare that um to to the cyber
security industry and and Israel's role
to that um and I think um there there's
qu there are quite a few questions um
that that are being asked um with a good
reason um comparing you know um um
Talent comparing startups Creation in
this space create um comparing the
infrastructure role of Israel um and I
think one of the interes things that
we're trying to look and I I'm really
passionate about is trying to figure out
what's our role um both because you know
at the end of the day I feel like it's a
it's a very important part of the
Israeli economy looking forward um and
both because of my micro you know dayto
day in my job to find the right
opportunities and and where are with the
Catalyst in this industry um and to Deep
dive a little bit into that so I think
um it's it's a very interesting thing to
to try to find um what are the
opportunities that Israel in a Global
Perspective is going to take in the AI
Revolution so it might not be
infrastructure as we were used to in
other verticals but and not only
application layer but middleware for
instance so we won't be the you know the
Nvidia of the world and we won't be the
open AI of the world but there is a very
very big opportunity in the middleware
um and it seems to me that this is a
very interesting area to Deep dive and
that that's like a big passion of mine I
I I love it and I think that the the
there's there's obviously New
Opportunities forming I'm not convinced
that we will not be the the the next
Nvidia of the world we we were the
melanox of the world and we've H um but
but I think that also you know it goes
in cycles and and technolog is changing
and shifting and I agree with you that
in today's landscape there's massive
opportunities those massive
opportunities I also experienced them a
lot in this middleware angle
where I also think there's very um
exceptional Talent here in terms of the
culture that we've created in our
country to to do that and and oi I I
always love talking to you as as a
friend and as a colleague and and and
I'm very thankful that you that you
agreed to join me here and and I hope
this was helpful and insightful and fun
for anybody who who joined and listened
to us so I really want to thank you for
taking the time to be here with me and
continuing doing amazing work with
teammate and and helping amazing
Founders um and best of luck thank you
for having me always a pleasure is
talking with you and chatting
[Music]